today we're talking about a new Cloud
region ml performance records and
securing your software supply chain I'm
Ryan and welcome to this week in Cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news at Google Cloud we recognize that
to be truly Global we must be local too
this means we need to be as close as
possible to our customers their
locations their regulations and their
values
today we're excited to announce another
step towards this goal our new Google
Cloud region in Paris France is
officially open
designed to help break down the barriers
to Cloud adoption in France the New
France region Europe West 9 puts
uniquely scalable sustainable secure and
Innovative technology within Arm's Reach
so that French organizations can Embrace
and drive digital transformation
head to the blog to learn more about the
specific economic impact and what this
means for our French customers ml driven
Innovation is fundamentally transforming
Computing enabling entirely new classes
of Internet services
and the recent release of mlper 2.0
results from the ml Commons Association
highlights the public availability of
the most powerful and efficient ml
infrastructure anywhere
Google's TPU V4 ml supercomputers set
performance records on five benchmarks
with an average speed up of 1.42x over
the next fastest non-google submission
and 1.5 X versus our ml perf 1.0
submission
even more compelling four of these
record runs were conducted on the
publicly available Google Cloud ml Hub
that we announce at Google I O
ml Hub runs out of our Oklahoma data
center which uses over 90 carbon free
energy
check the blog to see more game-changing
performance results
Google the internal development process
enables a level of security through code
review verified code provenance and
policy enforcement that minimizes
software supply chain and related risks
these Concepts go hand in hand with
improved developer productivity
what are the security risk points in
your software supply chain and how can
you mitigate them with Google Cloud
explore the ins and outs of common
threats that software development Supply
chains face and how you can secure your
own with the latest from Priyanka
vergadia on the blog if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list check out the link any
thoughts or ideas leave us a comment or
tweet us we'll see you in the cloud